this is what the 21st century is all
about Chris Brockman you and I were live
on the radio yes del to full you are to
the desperate we're also live on our
Instagram feed at Rich Eisen show IG
liveing is that what the kid says IG
live righteous liveing where IG liveing
this interview so let me take my glasses
off you can hear us on the app you can
hear us on the app and right now we're
also on the IG live page as I'm looking
at right now of Marquis Brown right
marquise you love your lot we're now
live where so I'm looking right now at
your phone all right did you lean it up
against the Old Spice product that you
brought here
oh yeah you know oh this fight has been
looking out for me you know sure from
the from Novato to the camera okay so
basically not only is Old Spice helping
get your skin game ready for the
National Football League it's actually
useful to lean your phone up against so
we can IG live out right now and talk to
your people yeah give my skin right so I
can look at my skin at the same time you
know they got the moisturizers shea
butter okay yeah no everybody can pick
it up at Target okay I look a little
shiny I'll be very honest with you but
that's just me yeah if I could only have
your hair that would be fantastic all
these beautiful red thank you that's
true but so why do you wear a Red Sox
cap everywhere you go I got a rep no
matter what 24/7 Martin he's brown I
just had I'm from Oklahoma good to see
you sir can I see him I just had Tom
McShea from the worldwide leader in
sports on one of the top evaluators in
the National Football League
he said he you have the greatest
functional speed he's ever evaluated
meaning that your speed getting in and
out of brakes is as great as he's ever
seen and he said quote I would take
Marquis Brown in the top 15 in sleep
very well Thursday night what do you
think about that it's known as is
appreciate it okay you know appreciate
my talent and you know I for the same
way enough for like you know I got very
good speed in and out of my breaks and
you know come from a lot of hard work
and trying to perfect my craft how are
you feeling how's your how's your foot
Oh feeling good you're good yeah because
you didn't run at the combine yeah yeah
well but it's somebody who's samel can
my running over other runs I appreciate
you not running at the combine
particularly bad for my for my 40-yard
dash tsommo cam is that because you were
not yet physically ready to do it or
what why didn't you run at the combine
yes I had surgery uh January 8th okay my
foot so I wasn't knowing new so again
that's that we're talking really March
you were nowhere near yeah was the last
time you ran period oh okay
so if I give you a 40-yard dash right
now how would you do right now I
probably wouldn't do it right now okay
so when would you when would you do it
middle of the summer something like that
yeah okay all right so you'd be ready
for training camp essentially is it okay
very good so let me ask you about a
couple things about your your teammate
before we get to you personally in Kyla
Murray first overall pick in the draft
potentially what's he like in the huddle
okay he just he got this or about it so
just confident and calm all the time
no matter you know games close or
blowing the team out he's always the
same and that's what he's gonna bring to
the hut are you gonna bring that
confidence and just it factor that you
know we're gonna get the job done so he
commands the huddle yeah okay and give
me an example where you got in a huddle
and he provided whatever was necessary
within it you got a good huddle story
involving Kyler Marie Marquis Brown
so we rarely heard him but you know
that's true too when we have those TV
timeouts and you know game like West
Virginia when this game is going back
and forth back and forth and you know he
gets in the huddle he look he you know
he gets the linemen going you know he
made sure he he talks to everybody in
that huddle and he's just gonna let you
know like yo don't worry like we got
this and we go out he don't make a play
and the X's and O's the comp there was a
big huge conversation at the very
beginning coming after the combine from
my colleague Charlie Cassidy at the NFL
that he had some sort of lack of
knowledge of the game X's and O's what
can you tell me about that I said that
statement is far from the truth
you know he's probably one of the
smartest players I've been around cuz
you know I studied his game you know a
lot and he knows his nose he knows you
know how
tat coverages he knows what's going to
be there and you know he's a guy that he
gets excited talking about football so
you know that came out you know I mean
everybody have their own opinion but I
don't think it was it was true okay
I have you listed here at five nine and
three eighths Marquis is that an when
you stand next to calamari who's taller
he listed at five to here's the thing
okay you are what you are at the combine
Yeah right and he did not have from what
I was told I was not in the room he did
not have like platform shoes are on or
anything like that no
so he's five he's five-ten mm-hmm he's
taller than you yeah okay
all right so playing football with Kyler
Murray just a last one describe that for
me what's what is that like uh it's been
fun man you know Kyler was my host so in
recruiting so we always been cool so
just playing with him he's like my
brother
what do you mean he was your promotion
recruiting for people to just know what
that is oh so when you gonna recruit
shows you know the team assigns you a
host to show you around campus right oh
to me help convince you to come to that
school right then Carla Murray was that
guy okay so what did he do to help
convince you to come to that school okay
very good but he did a good enough job
yeah cuz clearly you wound up at
Oklahoma okay your nickname is Hollywood
because that's the town in Florida where
you're from
yes okay what any anything else that's
Hollywood about you that I need to know
about I sound bright you know in the
license okay alright like that how did
you wind up at the college of the
canyons how did that happen uh it was in
Florida yeah it was recruiting one of my
friends that was on my team and you know
I had other junior colleges that I
couldn't went to but oats me you know
those guys they do a good job over there
and I felt they were going to be the
best fit to help me you know transition
to the next level okay so that's that's
in Southern California College of the
Kennedy okay
and you know one of the things that I'm
sure will be mentioned during our draft
coverage and all these networks as well
as you working at a Six Flags what did
you do with the Six Flags I was brought
up right out there know where first I
was in the like kids section
you know Bugs Bunny around there okay
that's a full-throttle I'm not a roller
coaster god but you know I am not either
I just yeah right I don't get on them
but you know it was a joy watching other
people get on okay so when you work the
kids you mean like you got the kids on a
Bugs Bunny ride or something like that
like the the fairies will we got him on
all the horses okay and then got people
on that roller coaster rods yeah how
much were you making there okay so I'm
just what was your hourly rate I just
want to know this because you're about
to get a big raise I don't remember
you'll remember lights in like 10 bucks
10 bucks an hour might you know my first
job on TV was okay
I was a sportscaster in Redding
California which is in the north part of
the state
my first hourly rate wage was 670 an
hour six dollars and 70 cents an hour
and then I got into the National
Football League and I'm not making 60 70
more that's about to happen for you on
Thursday night there's it when that
happens you sign your first contract
what's that going to feel like for you
it's gonna be a blessing and there's a
lot of hard work paid off you know this
is what you dream of and it's ready to
get make it all come true
okay what happens if you're drafted by
the Steelers marques what would happen
if that happens are we going up you know
they got a good franchise good
quarterback I feel like I come in and
help their office so you know I feel
like it'd be a good fit okay I'm just
trying to see if it's it a brown family
trait it's not one of the clay would Ben
Roethlisberger's anyway okay I
understand that I just wanted to kick
the tires on all that how often do you
talk to your cousin Antonia it's a it's
a every we could he be out
they're watching right now on Instagram
that was yes is he out there right now a
bee what happened used to follow me on
Twitter what happened maybe what's going
on
by the way I'm just looking right now I
see Old Spice right there
you look like mr. big chest right there
yourself is that a family trait thing
too we do a lot of push there's a lot of
bench press
how many how many pushups can you give
me no we paint around a 40 so okay so
let's say you do push-ups instead of 40
so I just if your cousin Antonio is out
there right now I'm just waving right
now on your Instagram feed do you have
an elliptical machine there go Cody for
Cody Cody Ford can be a Texan by the end
of the week Cody for the idea right
there yeah all right so they're all out
there is Connor out there right now
Kylie where are you Kylie probably is
well I mean I think your cousin Antonia
lives on Instagram last I checked I
think he actually spends every moment of
his life on Instagram so maybe he's out
there right now that would be amazing by
the way just watching you and so what do
you think last one for you here what do
you think you can bring to the NFL like
what what's your favorite route that you
run what do you see in the NFL that you
think you know what I can I can go out
there and I can bring this to the
National Football League game right now
I think it is big plays in general I
think I'm gonna come in and I'm gonna
I'm gonna make a lot of big plays down
the field short routes taking it a
distance just you know a lot I bring a
lot of excitement right I bet you can I
bet you can what's the strangest
question you got asked at the combine I
got something that the Sun rises in the
north you know when it son says I don't
know in the south for something like
that was weird well that is very weird
since it rises in the east and sets in
the west
yeah so they were telling you stuff that
was wrong just to see your reaction yeah
yeah I don't know what that's all about
did you get into a staring get a staring
contest uh not with somebody but I had
to stare as long as I could without
blinking
not at somebody just what at in the air
the stairs let me see how long you can
stir hold on a second
Marquis Brown you're at the combine okay
a team brings you into a room and says
to you we want you to stare into space
and not blink we want to see how long
you could do that did that happen yeah
that happened was that team the Seattle
Seahawks no actually I don't remember
what seamless because you were too busy
staring to focus on series running down
my eyes are you serious I mean you're
competitive yeah so how long how long
were you able to stay there I come in in
a zone come on you stared into space
first you just blinked for a solid
minute yeah were they trying to like did
they clap distracting images is watching
me this job was dead quiet in the room
could that be any weirder could it be
any weirder that is so bizarre I don't
even know what what did they learn from
that maybe your ability to take in a
playbook or focus on a route I'm serious
I don't even know what the hell that
would possibly show somebody I got to
tell you a minute that's impressive I'm
impressed by it so that's a new metric
all right so tell me about Old Spice
before we go right now because right now
it's across your mr. big chest right
there on your red t-shirt you're leaning
your phone up against let me get this
thing I don't mean to disturb it yeah we
got the Old Spice moisturizer right Oh
shea butter yeah okay by the way it's
great for leaning your phone up against
an Instagram live but it's also great
for for you yeah for sure they uh
they've been let help me get fresh you
know for the trap and just you know
moustache a bud and that's the best and
they also got you know another another
uh what it's called
like uh body wash okay yeah yeah
so they got a lavender they got the
moisturize shea butter happy mister they
got real benefits and uh really agree
five new body washes yeah
real benefits forged by real ingredients
in reading right here yeah like
moisturization and exfoliation let me
tell you if somebody can get in and out
of their breaks and exfoliate at the
same time it would be you yeah I don't
think I've ever said that in fifteen
years of NFL Draft to any anybody Old
Spice check it out at prime time
underscore jet Marquis Brown getting
ready to go into the National Football
League and I am just as a host what I do
for a living getting down on my hands
and knees hoping that you go to your
cousin's former team in the first round
of his left and playing Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania that would be great and
this is the first thing you should do
although not really do is if that
happens go and Facebook live your
coaches conversations after the asker
number 84 at primetime underscore jet on
both Twitter and Instagram what a
pleasure to meet you
pleasure to meet you good luck to you at
the next level I know you're gonna go
crush it go do it and then check out
Marquis Brown and a National Football
League near you he's now ending his
Instagram live feed so now let's really
talk trash about your cousin Oklahoma
sooner rod receiver Marquis Brown right
here on the Richard show for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app